thanks Michael I'm super excited to be
here and I'm happy to make this
interactive I know also my own
background is probably quite different
than some of yours in the audience in
the sense that I primarily do machine
learning and artificial intelligence so
if I use a term that you're not familiar
with just feel free to raise your hand
or if you think I know what that is but
that means something very different than
what it sounds like she means it to be
just let me know so if you look at the
news right now I'm probably almost any
day you look at the news there's some
article about why whether AI is gonna
automate humans and is this gonna happen
that we're gonna automate things like
being able to do skin cancer detection
are we going to automate taxi drivers
are we going to automate drone flying
and what is that going to be in what
sort of implications will that have on
society and the workforce and really a
lot of the history of artificial
intelligence has been about making
artificial humans and in some ways
thinking of maybe not explicitly trying
to replace humans but really trying to
make agents that can do anything that a
human can do so sort of trying to
replicate human abilities but I I think
of artificial intelligence in a quite
different way so who here has seen the
matrix so um you guys might remember the
following clip can you slide that thing
not yet
operator tank I need a pilot program for
a b2 to both helicopter hurry
[Music]
let's go
so this is probably exactly how your own
educational experiences have been that
you want to learn something and you just
download a program into your brain and
then instantly you can do the thing that
you wanted to do of course that is not
what we actually have right now in terms
of education education is mostly the
same as what it's been for a hundred
years but I think that this vision the
reason why I often show this clip of the
matrix is because I think it's a really
inspiring vision of what technology
could enable us to do
it's demand-driven education it's
real-time it's incredibly fast and it's
exactly targeted to what the user
actually wants to learn and so I think
it's this really amazing vision of what
education could be and what lifelong
learning really could be and Kintaro
Toyama who is a technologist who thinks
about information communication
technologies for international
development talks about technology being
an amplifier it's an amplifier of sort
of existing things in society and I
think that if we think of artificial
intelligence as being an amplifier that
to me is a much more exciting goal than
thinking about artificial intelligence
as being a replacement for us so um in
the work that I do I come from a
background of thinking about an area
called reinforcement learning which a
number of people may have heard about um
and in these sort of scenarios I think
of an agent that's trying to help a
human do something or augment the humans
own cape about capabilities in sort of a
loop like process so we might have an
agent that's represented by the computer
here that is feeding a math exercise to
a student and then the student responds
in some ways and then periodically we
might get some sort of reward signal
that indicates how good our there is the
way that the computer is teaching the
person so maybe we can see whether or
not the student has passed an exam and
there are really important questions
around here of what should that
objective function be you know is it
that they pass an exam is that that they
play our educational game for five more
minutes or is it whether they choose a
stem career so there are a lot of
different choices they are about what is
it even that we're trying to optimize
for so when I talk about reinforcement
learning we often talk about a policy
which is a mapping of past interactions
to the next activity and all
a lot of our goals and reinforcement
learning can be viewed as how do we
construct some way that our agent should
make decisions to maximize reward so it
should be a strategy for saying
depending on how the student has done so
far what is the next mass exercise to do
so that over time we're gonna optimize
our reward and it turns out that this
comes up not just in education but in
many different other types of domains so
we're also thinking about healthcare
examples in this situation from a
similar modeling framework and in these
cases you could think of let's give some
sort of medication dosage suggestion and
then we observe blood pressure and maybe
there's some penalty if the blood
pressure is too high or maybe there's
some other aspects about side effects
and we're trying to figure out a
strategy for how to trade shape like
provide drug dosages over time so we can
think about this in the context of
healthcare and we can think about this
in context of consumer modeling and
marketing so there are many different
types of domains where we have kind of
this interactive process where we have
an artificial agent that could be
interacting with a person and trying to
optimize something through a series of
interactions with that person now in
general reinforcement learning we call
that first thing we're doing whether
that's picking a problem or picking a
treatment suggestion as an action and
then we get some observation back and
then we have a reward signal so we can
have this generic framework for thinking
about this sort of continual process of
an agent selecting actions and then
getting some observations and so who
here has heard about the recent results
in go and Atari maybe not everybody so
there's been some really exciting
progress recently in video games like
Atari you you can now get human level
performance by artificial agents and
those agents are typically using these
type of reinforcement learning
algorithms and similarly in the game of
Go we now have exceeded human level
performance with go and a lot of the
ideas come from reinforcement learning
and again in robotics this is one of
Google's arm farms it's an arm farm
because you have many robots with a
single arm doing something and there's a
lot of interest in how we can use these
types of techniques in robotics as well
but as Michael mentioned one of my
primary interest is thinking about how
these sort of techniques apply when
there's a human in the loop and so
instead of there being a video game
we're trying to play we're trying to you
know help someone learn math that we're
trying to help a patient have a higher
quality of life and people are not the
same as robots or video games and of
course they're not the same but they're
not as they the same in a couple
important ways that change the type of
techniques that we need to develop so in
particular in the context of video games
it's often fairly cheap to try things
out so I can have my agent fail to you
know succeed at pong or some of the
other Atari games for on the order of
200 million steps and that is not a
hypothetical number and that is a real
number so you could do that but that's
really computation so you know we could
simulate that for like 12 hours
sometimes more like two weeks and then
we could have an agent that learns to
play these games really well and then we
often report the final performance so
now we've got an agent that plays this
game really well so it's often cheap to
try things or it's pretty easy to
simulate so we don't have perfect models
at the physics of the world but we can
do pretty pretty well so we can in these
sort of robotics examples we can often
write down pretty good simulators of how
the world works and then we can try to
use those to say construct a policy for
how to grasp an object when we think
about people it's quite different so
people I would argue are high stakes I
don't want to make a tutoring system
that only learns to teach people
fractions after I have not taught a
million people fractions so it's high
stakes the data I'm getting is from
really interacting with people and yet
they're also really hard to model so we
don't have really good models of student
learning we don't have great models of
human physiology and so we're not really
in either of these two camps which are
often explored in reinforcement learning
scenarios and so what I'm going to talk
about today is observe some of the
technical challenges that come up when
we're trying to do this human loop
reinforcement learning and also thinking
about some of the things that we do have
access to in these type of domains that
are really people focused and what are
the sort of technical challenges that
come up there and what can we do
what's the pageant that we're in the
case where we have a set of classrooms
called the a classrooms I mean in those
classrooms the students first got to do
an exercise on a computer and then an
exercise on a chalk board and they got a
score of 95 on an exam and then I have
this other set of classrooms called the
P classrooms where they did the opposite
order of the activities they first did
the chalkboard exercise and then a
computer exercise they got an average
score up in 92 and then you have a new
student who walks in and says okay what
do you want me to do we want to pick
something that's going to maximize the
score so if we did this what are the
questions well first of all what would
you do or what are the questions we'd
need to ask in order to make this
decision of what to do for a new person
right so it might be that classroom a is
kindergartners and classroom B is you
guys and so maybe I should say the
opposite way around given the scores and
and so there might be some really big
differences in the types of students in
a and M B is there anything else that we
should maybe ask
how many students very nature classroom
right so if it turns out that this is
you know classroom a is Michael and
classroom B is me then maybe we can't
really generalize from that to what we
should do for all new students another
thing that people sometimes suggest when
I bring this up is well is you know is
that test really actually even a
reliable indicator of whatever it is
they're learning like let's say they're
doing math exercises here and this was a
history test maybe that tells us nothing
about what we should be doing but yeah
all of those considerations so what is
the differences between these groups how
many people do we have and is this a
reliable indicator let's imagine this is
a reliable indicator this is really a
math test
that was really math exercises so this
challenge of doing kind of this
counterfactual reasoning of saying what
should we do what can we generalize from
our past experience is a really
foundational one and it comes up in many
domains so imagine something like
maintenance scheduling and we're doing a
collaborations with Siemens right now so
you might see there are different orders
when you could do maintenance or when
you could get your oil changed or things
like that and you want to optimize for
that you want to sort of optimize cost
over time and you have old data and you
can see what the outcomes were and
similarly in the case of health care
often now with electronic medical record
systems we're gonna have sequence of
treatments that are given to patients
and then we can observe their outcomes
we can observe you know how well are
they doing different measures of sort of
quality of life and what we'd like to be
able to do is use that information to
try to make better recommendations for
future patients but why is this hard
well it involves this counterfactual
reasoning and there's this really lovely
talk by Judea pearl who's sort of one of
the founders of causal reasoning at
least in computer science and he argues
that our ability to do counterfactual
reasoning is really a core aspect of
what it means to be human we can imagine
things that we haven't observed and so
we have to do that here because I didn't
tell you what would have happened in the
B classrooms like if those B students
had gotten the B classroom students had
gotten this other intervention the same
one as in the a classrooms we don't know
what would have happened we can't
observe these parallel universes we can
only observe a subset and we can't rerun
it the second challenge is
generalization so here we only have
two types of things we can do we can
either use a computer or chalkboard and
we can think about which or do we do
that in and so there's a very small
number of possibilities but if you start
to think about all the drugs that you
could prescribe all the different types
of medical interventions and also not
just doing this for two time steps but
for many time steps there's a huge
combinatorial explosion and we don't
want to try all of those it's probably
not the time in the university trial of
those and so we're gonna have to be able
to generalize somehow from our previous
experience to try to say okay would it
actually be better to use the computer
twice so in general this issue of saying
we do have access to some old data sort
of the data about decisions and their
outcomes and we want to use it to make
better decisions can be framed as
follows we're often calling this batch
data policy selection I mean again when
I say policy I mean this mapping from
given a scenario what decision should we
do so in this case let's say we have
this old data and we have a bunch of
different policies we could consider
these could be constructed using
reinforcement learning they could be
from experts they could be you know done
in different ways and then we want to
evaluate each of them so we want to say
how good given our old data do we think
each of these strategies would be if we
were to use them in the future
so should I teach my students using the
first thing or the second thing for all
future students and how good do I think
that'll be let's say in terms of their
test scores and then I probably want to
do some sort of policy selection at the
end and make actually a decision about
which one to then go try with my
students or deploy in the hospital etc
so I'll just give a little bit of
background my original interest in this
came from an educational game that we
were working on a few years ago this is
in collaboration was eran Popovich who
is a professor up at university of
washington and this is refraction
I think it's been played by around
500,000 students and it involves
splitting laser beams using fractions to
try to feed spaceships fuel them up and
we had data from the past and we wanted
to figure out maybe I can if I can play
a little bit of it here see it's a video
works
[Music]
no spaceship and what we wanted to
figure out there are different levels
which involve different fractions and
different types of spatial into spatial
configurations of different levels of
difficulty and so we wanted to be able
to order these to keep people engaged in
learning so in this scenario the policy
we're looking at is sort of some model
of player state some history of the
previous levels they've done and what
they've done in those levels and
deciding what the next level would give
them and our goal was to maximize
engagement which is just how many levels
do they play now you might argue is that
really the right optimization criteria
really we're going for learning and the
idea here is this is sort of a game
that's online there's no constraints on
people using it for a long time and
people generally use this for the order
of somewhere between four to six seven
levels and we wanted to increase how
long they we're using this and with the
idea being that is this is a ped
logically effective game then that
should also hopefully help them learn
more things and the old data that we had
was from about eleven thousand students
and one thing you could imagine doing in
this case is building some sort of
statistical predictive model so what I
mean by that here is we're just gonna
build a model that says if I'm in this
letter if the student has this here
series of history historical
interactions with a game and then I give
them a new level how will they gonna do
in this level maybe what they're gonna
do in this level and the reason we might
want to build the statistical model is
because then we can use a disease
simulator so now like I talked about
before how in robotics there's often
these great simulators of what it's like
to move a robotic arm now we have a
simulator of what it's like to be a
person playing this game and so then we
can try to just use reinforcement
learning to try to optimize a policy for
if that's really the right model of a
person what is the series of levels we
should give them to keep them engaged
but unfortunately there's some problems
with this so the model might not be good
I told you before that
models of people are hard even with deep
neural networks they're still hard and
so 11,000 data points is a reasonable
amount but it's not huge and so we're
probably not gonna have a perfect model
so if we have a bad model we know from
our theoretical results that we can get
a bad estimate of the of a policy so if
I pick a particular strategy for how to
show levels to a student and then I use
my model to estimate how many levels
that student will play I might my
estimate just might be wrong might be
off and that seems sort of reasonable
right like it seems like if we don't
have very good models we can't use them
as very good simulators here's what's
worse more accurate models can lead even
poorer performing policies so that seems
really bad right like I already told you
if our models bad we're gonna be in
trouble but no I'm saying actually even
if your models good you might still be
in trouble seems really bad right and so
why did this come up this was sort of an
interesting issue for us when we we
started it so on the x-axis here you
don't have to worry about the exact
details of the representation we're
using but essentially these are just a
line about more complicated models so on
the right hand side are really simple
models and on the left hand side are
still pretty simple models but a little
bit more complicated and we're looking
at two things here so the grey line is
log-likelihood which is on a held-out
test set of our eleven thousand data
points so let's say it was a 1,000 I
don't recall the exact number but let's
say it was 1,000 we built a statistical
model we saw how good was our model at
predicting what people would actually do
on that held-out test set so this is a
measure of how accurate is our
statistical model player behavior and
what this is saying is that gray line is
going up over time which is saying it is
better to have a slightly more
complicated model you're better able to
model player behavior if we have a more
complicated model okay but then what's
the black line doing the black line is
saying okay if you take that model you
pick the best policy that is optimized
for that model and then you run it in
the real world or so we're actually
using the offline estimation procedure
but we actually evaluate how good that
would be and it's getting worse
so we're if we use that model and then
try to get a good strategy for how to
map level
no student state two levels we're doing
worse over time
and with more complicated models and why
is that so this was sort of confusing to
us for a while and then I think it's a
really interesting issue so the issue is
um these models these statistical models
are just looking at predictive accuracy
so what do I mean by that well let's
imagine that you're trying to build a
robot that can make tea and the robot
can see everything in the kitchen it can
see the outside where there's a sunset
there's a kettle there's steam and it's
trying to use all of those features to
figure out a policy if okay given I see
the Sun set and the stove and the steam
do I take the coffeepot off or on and it
turns out the only thing that you need
to care about there is whether or not
the water is above a hundred degrees or
not it doesn't matter about the sunset
doesn't matter about you know any
weather there's a lot of steam or not
you just care about whether the water is
hot enough in order to make your
steaming beverage and I can get this
back up and the problem is is that if
you're building a predictive model it's
gonna try to model the sunset it's gonna
try to model the steam and it doesn't
know that what all you really care about
in terms of making good decisions is
whether your water is hot enough or not
so that's the problem is that you kind
of have a mismatch of objectives here
what we really want is a good policy
that's going to allow us to make good
decisions where we're optimizing for
here is predictive accuracy and so
there's a disjoint and so what this led
us to say is okay we don't necessarily
there data through this thing of trying
to be get accurate models of player
behavior we really just want a policy
that's gonna allow us to get
high-performing results helping our
students get engaged so as I mentioned
just to summarize that point a lot of
the prior work says if the model is good
the policy is good the problem is that
the model class you're using and the
features you're using might be wrong and
so particularly if you have small
amounts of data you might be very
misguided in a way that we were here and
it's very hard for us to know if our
model type is wrong with finite data and
this actually relates to a lot of other
challenges that are coming up right now
in robotics people often call this the
simulation two real problem
that you've got a simulator that is not
perfect you don't to say no how it's not
perfect so that when you deploy a
resulting policy in your robot fails to
grasp how do you know what went wrong so
we wanted to do something that was
robust to kind of this model class
mismatch and the subjective mismatch
that what we really care about is trying
to get a good policy out a good way to
help people learn and so we use a new
statistical estimator the important
sampling estimator and what it does is
it gets a direct evaluation of a
policies performance so there's no
modeling a player behavior at all we
just try to directly estimate how good
is this policy and the idea for those of
you who may not have seen this idea
before or is a refresher is that we had
sort of some distribution of student
outcomes before when we used our
previous strategy in this case it was
just randomly selecting levels for the
student and then we want to kind of
relay those to look more like the
distribution of outcomes we'd get under
the alternative policies so when we did
this we found that we could get a 30%
higher engagement than what we saw
before and this was significant for two
reasons the one was that we could
accurately predict this before we tried
it in the real world so that was showing
that this statistical estimator was
really a good prediction of how well we
were gonna do unlike the models and the
second is that there was room for
improvement that we could use these type
of reinforcement learning algorithms to
get a lot better results and I think the
intuition for that is that it's hard to
write down what level a student might do
at each point in these cases there's a
lot of things students are doing when
they interact with this sort of game and
so it was hard for game designers to
figure out exactly what that mapping
should be and that's exactly where
optimization and data might be helpful
now in general this - this technique of
important sampling can be high variance
the estimator can be quite enak quite
inaccurate and vary a lot and it's
variance can grow with the number of
decisions that are made so I mentioned
before that this previous game people
would only play it on the order of four
to six levels in some of our other
educational settings we're making many
more decisions the students are using
our tutoring system for 20 problems -
problems and so in those sort of
settings it can be much harder to do
this sort of estimation and so we've
been working on a lot of different
technical challenges that come up with
that another so this has been a general
big focus of our lab is how do we make
how can we use old data to try to get
better policies for the future use and
both in education and also in healthcare
and as we've gone through this we've
discovered some surprising things so it
turns out that sometimes you can have
statistical estimators of how good a
policy will do both of which are
unbiased which means that you're just as
a refresher that means that whatever
estimate you get of how good the policy
will be really is centered around what
its real value will be and the problem
is is that then when you make decisions
about that it can turn out it's still
not fair and that's because sometimes
you're gonna have much more variance in
one estimate than the other so when
you're finally trying to make a decision
about which thing do I deploy in the
future you can be systematically biased
against the better solution so we had a
best paper award for that last year and
I think it's a really interesting
technical issue because this stuff is
used and a lot of robotics problems in a
lot of other areas of reinforcement
learning so we're continuing to do a lot
of this work and I think that there's
some really interesting questions here
about how can we do this particularly in
these cases where it is really hard to
model people so the thing I want to talk
about is expanding this space so
wonderful other tutoring systems was
this histogram tutor histograms can be
thought of as a precursor to
understanding basic probability and
statistics and they tend to be really
confusing for people so things like
knowing what is on the y-axis of a
histogram are often really confusing
when you're first learning about them
and we had this vision of doing this
continually improving tutoring system
that was getting better and better the
more people it would teach so you know
the student we'd be doing problems
selected by our tutoring system the
student would be getting them right or
wrong at the end we do a post-test and
based on all of that data our system
would automatically change how it taught
people and it would just get better and
better and better and so be improving
across many many students that we're all
having this interaction process
and the problem was that over time the
tutoring system stopped giving some
problems to students so there was a
series of about eight skills here that
we were teaching and about six of them
stopped being taught so that was a
little strange because we were actually
trying to teach histograms um and then
this kind of gets back to this issue of
what is the reward function what are we
trying to optimize and what we were
trying to optimize in this case just to
briefly mention is we were trying to
look at essentially post tests so sort
of how good did they do at the end
divided by the square-root the number of
problems we gave them so what we were
fighting what we were doing here is we
were saying well we want to kind of
trade-off between learning effectiveness
and learning efficiency and so we want
to have them do really well but not
require you know if they can do really
well in ten problems instead of real
really rolling 50 problems of practice
it's better not to waste the students
time so we'll give less problems and the
problem was but it just didn't give any
problems for a whole bunch of skills and
so somebody have a hypothesis of what
had happened there why given that
objective function I know it's right
after lunch but like I so everybody's
probably in need of coffee too but it's
a great idea why given this objective
function it might stop teaching some
skills those were not a first test yes
so one thing would be maybe those skills
were not meant to post this which is
great question in fact they were all on
the post test so all the skills were on
the post test if they weren't then that
certainly yeah so the stree point do so
we did correct for that so that's a
great question and we if this here
strictly it would be zero we did make a
slight change that so it wouldn't be but
it's exactly along that line
so what would happen okay tries to give
me problems like these your problem
because it wants them together good
score so it sort of avoids the problems
people tend to miss a lot to each are
probably the skills you're trying to
teach yeah so that definitely should
happen and all these ideas are really
great even simpler than some of those
suggestions um the idea was that the
post-test score didn't change whether or
not we gave them any problems so if it
doesn't change you just don't give any
problems cuz you're gonna minimize the
bottom so if the top is a constant the
best thing to do is to give as few
problems as possible and it's a little
bit like if you go to a lecture a lot
and you realize the lecture isn't
helping you learn you've never had that
experience and so in that case you just
start to start to skip lecture or you
realize the textbook doesn't help you
learn and you stop reading the textbook
so what the system that basically self
diagnosed was that our beautiful content
that we had spent hours creating was
completely ineffective at helping people
learn for some of those skills and so
it's self optimized it was like I don't
need any of that the students seem to do
the same on the post-test whether we
give them this content or not so we'll
skip it so this was you know perhaps
slightly a failure of our curriculum um
but I think at a high level it
introduced this really interesting issue
which was it can self diagnose that
something's wrong and so there's two
levels of self Diagnostics here the
first is that none of our material is
being taught so that was good to know
but the second is that it couldn't reach
the performance we expected it to so we
were expecting that if we gave the
students right amount of problems
everybody would do well in the post-test
and what it was finding is that let's
say maybe you know everyone was giving
like around 70% on the post-test
regardless of how many problems they did
and so people just didn't learn the
material it wasn't that everybody had
already understood it they just weren't
learning and so if you as a human know
how good you want your system to be you
can realize as a gap there and so the
system says I'm done optimizing and
there's still a gap which means
something needs to change now in the
context of sort of classical
reinforcement learning you'd be stuck
can't do anything at this point because
that's your system and you've optimized
as well as you can and it's at 70% and
you're just done
but of course as humans that would be
very very sad if that was the case that
would mean things like the Zika virus
comes along and we'd be like well that's
too bad we don't have a virus for
vaccine for the Zika virus so guess
we're stuck you know but we don't do
that we invent new things all the time
like we encounter new problems for which
we have no existing solution and we
invent something and the context of
reinforcement learning that would be
called inventing new actions so we see
that we are stuck and we invent new
things and similarly there are times
where we realize we don't have the
information we need to be able to make
the type of decisions we need to and so
we invent new sensors to try to set a
new things like the Hubble Space
Telescope and so why can't we have that
in the context of these sort of human
loop systems so this again is a big
distinction because you know in playing
go I can't suddenly decide that I'm
gonna use a new move which is like take
all of the other person's pieces or to
declare victory right and we can't do
that in those sort of closed systems
same an Atari right I can't suddenly
teleport my agent to the final room but
we can do that sort of thing in a lot of
human Vegas Eden applications we can
invent a radically better patient
treatment so in thinking about this in
the context of human loop reinforcement
learning we want to augment the system
so that it's no longer this kind of
closed box but we can have outside input
so the first thing we started thinking
about is well how could we have an agent
reach out to a human maybe an expert
maybe a crowd and say hey I've optimized
as well as I could and everyone's still
only at 70% what should I do like I need
another video to explain histograms or I
need another problem can you help me out
but we wanted to do this in a way to
kind of direct the human effort people
are busy and we'd like the system to say
alright well given my optimization of
this system and where I think people
might be failing to learn where I think
the system is currently doing poorly can
you add something exactly there so the
way we did this just to briefly sort of
give some of the equations is that we've
tried to think about the local
improvement we could have so imagine
that there's some part there's some
situation where the student isn't
understanding something and you could
introduce the perfect explanation how
much of the difference
make so we tried to quantify that which
requires us to have some upper bounds on
sort of how good it could be if we were
at this new action so can we imagine
sort of introducing the perfect vaccine
through Zika virus or could we imagine
sort of introducing this perfect
explanation and how student learning
would go later on and one of the
challenges that come up when we do this
is that this is all during the process
as the system is itself optimising and
so often there's a lot of uncertainty in
terms of how the system is currently
performing and so one of the things that
we came up with is to say don't add in
actions in places in the world where the
existing action might already be good
enough and you just don't have enough
data yet to tell that add in actions in
the places where you have a lot of
evidence that you are not doing well so
like if I've just given one lecture in
the class on a topic that's really hard
to learn maybe that was a good lecture
and we just need some more practice with
that but if I've given you know this
lecture to 30 classes and nobody ever
understands it that it's probably time
to do something new so what we did to
try to check how well this worked was we
did some different simulations and this
is kind of a sort of completely toy
domain and the idea here is to say well
what if there's a really large action
space can we kind of grow over time to
add in these new actions and get good
performance and the idea is that this
sort of directed way of add scheme to
augment the space and get better actions
for your agent is like from overtime is
better than either doing something where
you just get random actions or where you
try to like think of things that are
just like frequently visited so you
could imagine just saying well what are
lots of places where people get stuck is
that the right place to add a new
explanation or you could do it in this
more targeted way and the targeted way
is better and another thing that I
thought was interesting again this is in
simulation but we tried to say well what
if the advice you're getting from the
human when you ask for these new ideas
is not always good so sometimes you know
maybe like I try to think of a new
lecture and it's bad and that is not
effective
the nice thing we can find here is that
the system is still learning about what
actions are effective or not so as long
as some of the new actions that are
being added are helpful its performance
goes up over time because it can learn
to do
discard the bad suggestions because in
this case somebody actions
I'm the random here is just how you're
selecting weird to add in those actions
and some of them are still so then and
I'll return to this example later but
and so then we started to think about
how could we do this for a real
educational setting this is again a game
that was developed by Zirin Popovich's
lab and this is math word problems and
the idea is that we often many tutoring
systems we give students hints and these
hints themselves can be thought of as an
action and they're not always very good
by game designers or had the people that
the researchers involved and sometimes
they're good and sometimes they're not
so good and so we thought that we could
ask people to figure out you know to add
a new hints exactly where we think it's
not currently being very effective I'll
return to this example in a sec so
another thing that we thought about in
this case is well all right maybe the
action space is good but maybe we're
missing something maybe there's
something about the student or about the
person that we're missing that would
allow us to make better decisions so for
example maybe I'm talking to a student
or maybe yeah and I realize halfway
through the question the the discussion
that maybe they don't actually know
algebra and so then if I ask them do you
know algebra and I can provide a much
better explanation than just assuming
that they knew algebra or just sort of
trying to pick the best explanation
regardless of whether they know algebra
or not so it is often the case that
additional features allow us to make
better decisions but there's a lot of
reasons not to put in all possible
features in advance it tends to mean
that we need more data to learn a good
policy so our idea is to think about
whether we can do this strategically can
we think about this in a utility driven
way if we were to add in a new feature
could we make better decisions so this
is something ongoing work with my
question Rampton and just as a really
small example some of you guys might
have seen these before if you've taken a
I this code this is a grid world and
here's a very small toy domain that we
often think about it
and in this scenario it's only those big
black boxes which are kind of the state
of the world so there are nine states in
the world that s means a start state
that J means a goal state and you have
basically a little robot that's trying
to learn how to traverse and the thing
is is that this is the world that it
sees so it only sees like those nine
states inside of the big block black
boxes but in reality the world is very
complicated
at least more complicated than that
there's things like rainy States and
windy states which cause its dynamics to
move in different ways and so the real
policy can depend on more distinctions
than it currently has access to and so
what Rampton developed is an algorithm
that tries to adaptively split the state
space and refine things based on utility
based on the idea that it uses its data
it hypothesizes whether or not there
could be additional latent features that
it would allow it to make better
decisions if it thinks it would it
splits and that sort of simulating
asking a human hey I think there might
be additional feature here that if I
knew it
I could make better decisions can you
help me out and what are the interesting
things we found here is that the number
of distinctions it was making was still
smaller than if you would split the
entire space so you may not need to make
all the distinctions in the original
domain yeah oh well if I only understood
like this concept you because you may
not be aware that that yes yeah no I
think it's a really interesting issue
and I will also get back to that in when
we return to the word examples so at a
high level
our vision here is to say how can we use
this human expert or a crowd to try to
make the system better to change the
definition the spec of the system if you
will over time so that we're getting the
system it's not only self improving but
it's kind of expanding in scope to try
to really achieve the performance we
want but as Michael just mentioned
including humans loop has some
limitations as well so well let me first
just talk about sort of the grant more
grand scheme and I'll get back to that
um so this can be used in other ways too
this could be used in crowd work so this
is some work that with my students and
Rudy and then our collaborators Eric
Horvitz and Ajay Kumar and in this case
we were thinking about crowd work tasks
where we would like to train people to
be able to do more
located tasks and one of the challenges
in this case is that we may not know
what's the right way to train them to do
more complicated tasks and it also takes
time to write those sort of instructions
and so we were curious about whether we
could have a scenario where because we
know that worked examples are often
helpful could we take the solutions that
people are generating and use them to
train the crowd workers so this is we
publish this think highly years ago to
show that yes you can use sort of the
old solutions to try to bootstrap and
teach future people how to do this task
and in general you could imagine sort of
a whole ecosystem where if you're doing
a complicated task you also need to be
able to validate and grade the solutions
that people are generating and so you
could be using the crowd both to create
solutions use those solutions to train
the crowd workers and getting the crowd
to validate those the thing that I think
is interesting about this site type of
vision is saying well really we could be
using machine learning to try to kind of
select which solutions are effective for
teaching those might not be the same
ones that are actually the best
solutions there can be differences
between how you want to demonstrate and
how you want to teach but that we could
serve have this closed loop system here
which is leveraging both people
particularly for the invention of the
new content and machine learning to try
to refine it but let's get back to that
issue that Michael was just meandering
about metacognition so we haven't looked
at that issue in terms of the feature
splitting but we have looked at some
limitations of asking people for actions
so a lot of work right now in
reinforcement learning and robotics and
AI is thinking about this issue of
learning from demonstration where you
have someone demonstrate an expert like
how to pick up a cup or you know many
different types of aspects particularly
robotics but teaching is not the same as
doing and this has been noted before and
it's not clear always that learning from
demonstrations is the best and teaching
might be much better but people might
have challenges so teaching is really
hard and if we looked at what was
happening in this case so we had
education students who are providing
these hits to the machine that then were
being used
eh later students so you can think of
the system which is this math world
problem system periodically we ask
education grad students hey the system
isn't working very well can you provide
some new hints that students can use to
learn and then we keep going and the
problem was is it made no difference so
it didn't seem like the system was
really getting better over time and when
we dug into this we realized it was
really hard for people to know what new
hints to provide and I think it was hard
from a couple things even though their
general sort of education experts
they're not an expert in this particular
sub game and they're not the same
demographic as the people play in this
particular sub game there's a lot of
delayed feedback about whether or not
how they were teaching the agent was
effective or not
it takes a while to assess that just
like in a lot of teaching and whether or
not you're being effective and we
weren't doing any training of people to
try to help them do this and so you know
when people are sort of teaching or
thinking about how to teach another
person I think we sort of want them in
this case to be able to think about what
is the robot doing or what is the agent
doing and what is the tasks involved and
how can we help train the trainers so
think of the humans training the machine
in this case but we may need to educate
and train the trainers in order for them
to be able to provide effective feedback
and I think as we start to generally
think about this closer interaction
between machines and humans and through
these more collaborative aspects it's
gonna be really important because there
will be many people interacting with
machine learning algorithms that are not
machine learning experts and allowing to
train them to provide effective feedback
at labels and interactions with the with
the machines I think will be really
important so just to summarize I talked
a bit about how do we learn from the
past to try to decide the future I
talked about how we could maybe expand
the space of actions and observations in
order to make systems that can
outperform their original specifications
and I also talked a bit about how I
think we're going to need to change some
of the interaction between human and
machine learning in order to get truly
effective systems I just want to thank
my group and open it up to any questions
there's type of our discussion feedback
questions suggestions of new actions she
could take so I think the question of
learning reward systems is super
interesting I think in particularly to
go back to the beginning it was Trinity
who wanted to fly a helicopter
she had a particular goal and I think
ideally we'll make all these systems
where we could sort of expose people's
reward or objectives and then support
them towards doing that I think in our
own work we haven't we've normally been
in situations where we've imposed the
reward structure like post-test
performance or engagement there's
certainly a lot of interesting work on
preference learning where you try to
infer say from people's actions what
their reward function is or sometimes
it's called inverse reinforcement
learning you try to infer their reward
but I think that's a really interesting
issue I also think is a really into
particularly the context of coaching and
training of how do you grow someone's
reward function like I think there's
often this challenge between saying this
is maybe what you currently want but
maybe you're not aware of these other
potential outcomes and so like a good
coach or a mentor often exposes you to
additional opportunities that then you
decide you incorporate as part of your
goals
this is not what I'm trying to reason
through like in the in our educational
system often there's a lot of value
placed on keeping someone within the
system so maybe you're struggling to
learn Matt you know well let's keep you
around and put you into a different math
Lane or something so that you stay
around and that seems to be optimizing
for some sort of reward criteria that
might be different than if we were just
saying try to maximize the amount that
they learn or something like this
because you're subject to budget
constraints like which might I do what
this thing didn't say okay we need to
cut them out of the system they're not
learning math and this feels to me like
is I don't know which one's better
although I have a hunch it seems like
part of this is about the formulation of
effective reward strategies as we're
moving into these words socio technical
domains how do we reason about what is
it what are these rewards and when are
we gonna go to certain biopic outcomes I
guess I a couple thoughts within that so
one thing that I find interesting in
terms of how people use these actual
systems so a lot of these sort of more
personalized systems um you can also
skip people ahead and in terms of
keeping people coherently within a class
it's really hard to teach people of
which some people are in unit one and
some people are unit twenty and so
people often get caught up which means
they're just advanced and so maybe like
at some point you know you're struggling
you're still on unit 1 of pre-algebra
but everybody else is now halfway
through algebra in your teacher just
moves you up and they observe that
empirically a lot and so people aren't
necessarily following these personalized
systems always because it is really hard
in the classroom to have people being
that disparate it's very hard teacher
load I think in terms of maybe the
second thing of saying like you know
what is the was the reward function I
mean I think another big issue like if
we look at the sort of the No Child Left
Behind the objective there is that maybe
everybody passes you know gets to a
sufficient level as opposed to
optimizing the expected outcome so maybe
that's going to be a little bit lower
and I think there's a tension often
between saying
and we have constraints that make sure
that you make guarantees for the
individual as well as sort of improve
the average or the improve the expected
amount I think ideally another thing too
is that you would like society to sort
of explicitly decide this is the
longer-term objective which is probably
not just passing this year's test and
it's like you know reducing crime rates
later getting into college having long
term jobs and the problem right with
that is having these very long-term data
streams in the credit assignment there
has been some really cool work looking
at tutoring system work and LAN in like
sort of eighth grade and later stem
career choice and college so when we
have those data sets I think that's
really exciting because those are really
the outcomes we would like it's the kind
of space that I end up having to
navigate in many different ways
incentives that the person in the system
are not wholly rational right and so you
know if you're trying to optimize my
test performance you know like if at
some point I don't think I'm gonna learn
anymore I might just start messing up
the system or you know answering
randomly doing things that like the
system now miss models the entire ready
and these seem like really interesting
questions to be able to unpack yeah so I
think also a lot of the things another
point that you just brought up here is
that these systems are generally
thinking if the person is kind of a
black box and also but but a sort of a
unassuming black box it's not an active
Alex and they could be adversarial they
could be cooperative and that should
change things in terms of how we teach
it how we interact and there's certainly
been a lot of work on gaming the system
and how people game or exploit features
of the RL systems but I think there's
been less work on looking at the
cooperative setting like I want to learn
this
you want me to learn this can I need way
less data if I can reason about the
agent actively choosing examples
assumption of action space sort of
thinking about open world assumptions in
not sure if the objective is their
reward function is the right
think of it or list in the in the actor
right that there are unobserved things
about the actor or that their energy
might shift yes exactly and those are
bringing out which of those parts of the
key features to be doing optimization
over or to consider in terms of
robustness one thing we try to think
about is robustness to failure your
models
LEM that whatever model we use is going
to be limited and so how can we try to
reason about them to be robust
especially in education maybe in the
context of institutionalized racism or
bias of teachers where certain classes
of students have not been encouraged or
had expectations so they haven't tried
for instance more advanced problems
because they weren't provided to them so
how do you deal with that yeah I think
that's a super interesting issues so in
these cases we have not been addressing
it and some of our are their work if you
know what some of those variables might
be that you want to actively correct
against we have developed algorithms for
how to do that so in the kind of word of
machine learning supervised learning
case we've looked at let's say for
predicting entrance to college can we
systematically make sure that you don't
systematically over predict for one
group and under predict for another
group and you if you know what those are
the things are that you want to try to
protect against then you can put it in
the system you can make sure your
solution respects that and solves for
that I think one very big challenge
still is if what if they're late and
ones that are you they're correlated
with that thing you don't realize or if
there are features that you're like oh
in retrospect I should have included
religion or I should have can you know
controlled for X that you miss and then
your system will tend to exploit that
information that might be sort of
indirectly related to zip code or
something like that so I think that
that's a really big challenge in machine
learning right now
being with change in preferences for who
the actual user over time at the
beginning they might want to learn
something or they desire to learn and
then that at some point they may change
in many times as Michael said is
irrational chose because fashion with
the complicity of the irrationality of
human being over time well we certainly
don't completely I think the issue of
non-stationarity is super interesting we
had a paper recently looking at how do
you detect that so how do you detect
when this the system has changed and
related to that Steve Collins and I are
starting a new collaboration he's a
mechanical engineering and where he has
an exoskeleton and you're trying to
optimize the parameters the exoskeleton
for a person and what are they really
interesting things is that it can take
people a while to learn how to wear an
exoskeleton and so they're
non-stationary during that time period
and then after that you're kind of
teaching them this is what does
exoskeleton this is how to change your
gait and after that you want to optimize
the parameters for that person and so
we're trying to look at how can you tell
whether the system is non-stationary
versus when it's converged and can you
detect those changes so I think it's a
really interesting issue and that often
people will be changing those over time
maybe they start they enroll in a MOOC
and they don't they're just gonna learn
a little bit about history and then they
decide they love it and so now they've
changed it and in some cases you can ask
sometimes I think it's fully observable
or it's worth asking and in other cases
it might be harder to ask and so you
might want to say hey you know there it
seems like things have changed like your
pattern or behavior has changed and that
that comes up in like drop out
predictors too so there's some work on
that to try to detect it but they're not
always modeling all the dynamics
and what do you see as the future of the
inflating system always gonna be a
supplement to I think it's very unlikely
that universities are sort of like
collective learning institutions will go
away because I think there's a lot of
other aspects that come right now from
like the social interactions and yeah
and so I think it's doubtful that people
will just be interacting like with their
own tablet that's provided they're like
learning coach forever um but I think
they could have a much larger role and
particularly in lifelong learning I
think that as particularly with AI
automation I think people are gonna need
to do a lot more lifelong training and I
think having sort of a personalised
coach that comes with you along that
journey could be way more effective than
the types of ways we do education right
now like right now I so Nicky Couture
Geoff big earner I had who were
professors HCI and CMU had a project
couple years ago called the question
reader with the idea being if I want to
learn a new topic there's kind of no
nice middle ground either I could like
you know just like start with like a
course which assumes no background or I
have these really high cost ones of like
bugging my colleague to sit down with me
for three hours and teach me and that if
I just do a web search there's no
personalization of my background
knowledge and and how would we create a
system that could create a personalized
tutoring system for me and I think that
sort of stuff is stuff that we could
reach you know that we could start being
up to dynamically select material that
says okay I'm I know something about
optimization and reinforcement learning
so this is the type of material I should
give to her for learning new things
last question do you think we're like to
focus on trying to like really design
for success and we should be working on
design for failure like when these
algorithms fail should we then use that
as an opportunity to like you know if
there's something new about these there
may be through interaction she's saying
the computer can say like I'm not
freaking idea why should I do now like
why don't you tell me what to do as
opposed to like trying always to be
right yeah that's an interesting
question like you know so can their
system sort of figure out when it
doesn't know and then maybe just you
know reach out to a human or reach out
for augmentation and I think that's a
really interesting question I think
there's cases we could do that I guess
I'll just say I thought you're gonna go
to a different direction which is should
we be optimization for student success
like should that be the objective and I
have a lot of thoughts about that and I
think one of the new areas that I'm
really excited about is trying to
optimize not things like which activity
to give but try to decide things like
metacognitive strategies or do things
like mindset interventions or impostor
syndrome or belonging interventions
which from some of the psychologists
here at Stanford have shown to have
enormous implications and they're really
really cool interventions because they
have these recursive effects that if you
can change if give people's different
theories of how they can interpret their
own experiences then that can have huge
cursive effects on how they can take
advantage of opportunities and so I
think if we can put those inside of
tutoring systems both we could
personalize those and we could scale up
their impact and so I'm much more
excited about those these days rather
than figuring out you know video then
problem or problem than video she's
around you can take her courses on the
reinforcement learning and other kinds
of cool things you can go researching
collaborate with her research you can
swing by her office hours and just chat
about cool things
you